[Applause]
waking up in bed getting steamy in a
sauna and some naughty teasing making
sure is it being shy with ruber new
shirtless Flame Machine Gun Kelly in his
just release video for bloody valentine
it's pretty racy and dropped just two
days after Megan's estranged husband
Brian Austin Green confirmed their split
on his podcast even referencing the
singer she said he's just been a really
good friend which she needed we're told
the video's supposed to show a twisted
love story between two characters so are
there sparks in real life this isn't
something new for us this is something
new for people to experience and hear
about in the press I don't want her to
be looked at in a negative way or him to
be looked at in a negative way there is
no story there now to an exclusive with
Lady Gaga revealing her sobriety
struggles I've flirted with the idea of
sobriety I'm not there yet
you kiss me in an interview with Apple
music Zane Lowe dropping tomorrow a
pink-haired mother monster describes how
she turned to alcohol to cope with
chronic fibromyalgia pain they won't
give me any narcotics because it's not
healthy for me part of my healing
process is going well
I can either lash the hell out of myself
every day for continuing to drink or I
can just be happy that I'm still alive
and keep going
gaga has a new album coming out and a
new outlook acceptance can't be thin
enough you can't be hot enough you can't
be rich enough
I am good enough it's not perfect but
wabi-sabi
you know I'm perfectly imperfect
[Music]